[Music]
hi god i was muted i do that
every time
i never forget to unmute when i'm
streaming hi hello my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's oh boy nothing was wrong with
you i'm just an idiot this is where if i
was editing this i would pause the video
and talk about what a giant fool i am
however
i have five nights at freddy's to play
yeah i know i know guys i know i'm very
dumb i get that i understand that
and i'm fine with that i've accepted
this about myself so if everyone is here
which i'm assuming
i'm gonna just go for it um but before i
do
going back to where i was before
what i'm gonna do
hour 11 p.m
wait oh okay i was about to say that
that didn't make any sense at all so
what i'm gonna do
is i'm actually going to start it a
little bit
before
because i know that the time is going to
go no matter what
what i want to do is i want to get that
security office done before all of the
golf stuff
and i'm thinking
i'm thinking
that
if i do that that'll be a little easier
on me
you know what i mean it might still go
to six a.m and then make me go to the
front of the place which is fine i'm
okay with that
but
hopefully it means that i'll have less
to do
after i can't save which is the big
problem
so i'm going to go back to 5 a.m it was
like 5 50 or something like that and i'm
gonna go all the way
until i get to some place
uh
the whatever it was i don't even
remember what it was what was it
what was it i have no idea
but okay let me go up the main elevator
uh yeah freddie is not there yet
i'm ready
so i'm gonna go up the main elevator i'm
gonna go up to that security office let
me just make sure maybe maybe it's not
even a mission here
office office
ah no there it is so it's still here as
an objective so if i can get this done
maybe i'll have a little bit of a better
time at this
yeah hello everybody
thank you so much yes i was dumb yes it
is fine
okay and yes this is live so hello
everybody yep
i'm good and and i did see all the
comments of a lot of people saying oh
you can shoot the security bots now i've
tried that before i've tried that and it
didn't work so if i shoot a security bot
right now and it works i'm going to be
so mad because i did that and it didn't
work
so if it magically works
you know i just don't know what i'm
gonna do i tried it a long time ago when
i first got the gun and i was like whoa
don't work i guess that's fine
whatever but if it works i swear
i'm gonna be so mad i'm gonna be so mad
c c c c c
see it does nothing
unless i missed which is also possible
because my aim was pretty terrible there
but
it don't work
i don't think it worked anyway it didn't
work there therefore it never works
everybody shut up it's fine
see i'll try again on this goober
i gotta get him like
right now see it don't it don't work run
please oh my god run please
c
in the eyes yeah how am i gonna hit him
directly in the eyes
i didn't have to hit anything else in
the eyes
so it don't
work
you know it just
it works on you why does it work on you
what's the point of that
unless i'm not getting them in the eyes
which
frankly
that's a bit of a ridiculous requirement
with no reticle it's like impossible to
hit that target from where it is
so anyway i'm gonna go to this
maybe it works on these guys or
something i don't know
get my charge back or whatever
hey shut up
all right so i'm going to
with the camera okay
i don't have the camera
have you guys not been paying attention
the entire time that i've been playing
this game i don't
have it
i got the laser and even when i went to
monty golf and got the
camera
i was not able to utilize
the camera
because it just
didn't work all right i'm setting on my
camera so i know which ones i need to
press so this one this one and this one
okay
see the problem is with doing this like
it's not like this is terribly hard
but it is a thing where
i don't necessarily know what i'm
dealing with because i'm all sight
reading it you know what i mean so i
have to see it for the first time
no matter what
press three oh i'm pressing three guess
what
i don't have it and i did that before
when i got the camera
maybe later it'll be fine
you with your advice this is why you
don't get a privilege to speak
all right
so i'm watching very careful what is
that over there i don't know what that
is
what's going on it's like a
all right
where are you going buddy where are you
going
where are you going pal
so this like now that i've done this
before and i know how it goes it's not
going to be that bad i'm hoping so
you're going that way so i'm going to
position myself
right here
can i if i have to get that close to it
okay did we just have a mommy pop out
there
i'm just gonna wait and see
okay
what are you doing
just checking to see if monty's gonna
pop out
oh my god
there's a behind entrance
is there a behind i don't have a camera
back there
i don't have a camera back there
how did you sneak up on me
oh that is
that is some
meanness
all right then
if that's how we're gonna be
hey pal
yeah you're still beautiful sure
okay
see it's much more manageable
it's much more manageable
if i know what i'm dealing with
this does feel classic five nights at
freddy's though
uh-huh
sure
you're only trying to help me
well this is awfully nice of them
i could just close the doors from here
on out and i'd
what
what i'm so confused what just happened
okay
seems
fine
hello monty
i don't like that whatever that is
okay it's fine
okay you're done
i i hate i just need a little work done
uh-huh
well everything is behaving
normally
why are you hiding from me
okay see there we go
i got that
perfect excellent so i got the prize
counter
security cameras
what does that even mean
what does that even mean and it didn't
go to 6am
which maybe time will only move forward
when i get that last piece which means
that i could save
right now
i can save
i'm going to make a new slot
i have saved
wouldn't you know it
oh what a magical experience
being able to save okay
i saved so now i just go to the prize
counter wherever that is
here oh
oh my god
good thing i saved
working perfectly good thing i saved
it's a damn good thing i saved then
right
it's a damn good thing okay this is
great
this is great this is fantastic because
now
i can go i can't go to monty golf just
yet because i don't have the party pass
for that and there's no other way to get
in there i can only get that towards the
end of the game
all right that's good
so let me just go in
why are you in there
where are you in there
i'm not seeing you
oh you're there interesting
interesting
okay
this is fine you know what
i'm sorry
what happened
i don't know but
there must be something important in
here because why else would they have me
come in here right
why are you hiding from me honestly i
have no idea
okay
so what could possibly be in the prize
counter area
that i needed to get
i see nothing
i see a whole lot of nothing
survive until freddy i did that but it
doesn't say i
did that
okay all right that's fine
good
um there's an elevator here i don't know
where the elevator would go
is it accessible
nope okay so i can't go in that elevator
those are out of order that's open over
there
where is roxy
oh there is roxy there is roxy roxy is
there rocks he's there
we're fine
what is oh
that's strange
so i'm
here wherever here is
interesting
probably just like another collectible
or something i doubt that they're going
to give me another party pass
or something like that
emergency exit
well awfully convenient that that's
closed off really appreciate that
okay grab the security badge i thought i
did i grabbed it first thing
pretty sure
could it be more lore
more drawing
look at him he's adorable
wow
well that was
eventful and
rewarding
okay but it doesn't matter because i'm
gonna go back to the office and just
double check that i got the security
you can't see
it's not fair
he must be cheating
you can't hide forever
totally fine
because she's blind
okay good
good good okay i'm gonna head back to
the office real quick just double check
i don't think that there's anything else
over there there might be something else
over here but where i can't quite tell
there's not really like an objective or
something and i can't get through well i
can get through there where does that go
why are you hiding oh
oh monty here why are you why are you
hanging out with your pinatas over there
what is that all about
where'd this go
whoa
what is this
what the hell is this
well this is terrifying
what
i have no idea where i am
oh
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership
wait
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
you worked
they just don't
play an animation
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership
so it works
it works it just doesn't
but i do have to hit him like right in
the eye
but also
what
okay i did get it okay i did get that
okay that's fine
that's totally fine
that's a hundred percent a-okay
i'm just gonna save again
wait they have a no there's a targeting
thing in
oh i don't understand you
why would it not be on my default
[Music]
okay all right all right oh man oh man
oh man
what is the point of this legend it
doesn't work i i don't know anymore i
don't know anymore guys
but it's fine
it's totally
fine
so what i need to do now
is to
is to uh
i need to see if there's any other
security office because i only have
level seven
and level seven
is not quite good enough
well you don't work whatever that's fine
level seven isn't quite good enough to
what i need to get
uh
like
the highest level of security which is
level 10. so there's three other places
i know there's one in monty golf i
definitely got the one in laser tag let
me go out to the atrium that'll help
then i'll be able to see wham
god i don't know why those aren't making
the noises they did before
back of the head don't work
that's fine i'm gonna go back out to the
atrium i definitely didn't get anything
from the bowling alley
a little laggy here
that's fine
i think if i walk by a charging station
it'll also recharge but let me double
check nah it don't work
that's my flashlight and i'm good okay
there was something back here i know
there was a prize right here
okay
oh okay
okay okay fizzy fast i bet if i get all
those like my sprint upgrades or
something no spoilers in chat i bet you
all are spoiling me heavily but no
spoilers i don't need any help i don't
need any assistance i'm great at this
game and i'm a good gamer in general i
love gaming
come here show me your eyeballs show me
them peepers
okay i have terrible shot even if i have
the reticle
whoa
you know what never needed it didn't
need it anyway
didn't even need it
pampering with fazbear automated stuff
okay
so i got the security office there the
prize counter i did that i don't even
know why i needed to do that but i did
that
um let me get a good look at this place
so
that's monty golf but i can't get in
there until i get the party pass kids
cove
what's kid's cove have i been to kids
cove i don't know if i've been to kids
cove i did fazer blast
i did roxy raceway i already got a lot
of the early ones so i'm betting it's in
places that i have not been before there
might be one in bonnie bowl
there might
there might be one in bonnie bowl that i
missed so let me go back to bonnie bowl
hmm interesting also it says there's a
level four
where in the hell is there level four
ooh
the fast kade goes to level four that's
right and i did get a security badge
from in there that's the fazcade the
dance party where we never actually saw
freddy dance wham tampering with fazbear
automated staff will result in
suspension of your membership man this
targeting thing who'd have thought being
able to see where you aim
when tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension and
remember hampering with fazbear
will result in suspension
what's over there is there's something
over there yeah i'm just gonna go
straight up to uh
the bowling alley
and just go there there's no level 10 i
don't believe you i don't believe you
i do not believe
i refuse to believe
[Music]
no it didn't allow me to bring freddie
up to the uh the
the arcade the dance party
i wish it were so i tried desperately
whoa
good thing they're blind okay i don't
know if there's gonna be a security
office in here or i don't know if i've
already
got it
yeah
yeah i think they patched it out so that
freddie no longer can open uh
your memory
automated yeah i don't think freddie can
open those doors anymore it was kind of
like a bug
they didn't like that so they didn't
they didn't keep that up
here no that's right there's probably a
way to get back behind the bowling no
there's nothing over there and it's just
that down there
and that's just the bathroom over there
maybe there isn't one here
it's entirely possible
yeah i know i'm just like killing time
until i actually go and do the damn
thing with
freddy
getting outside and all that
but i'm just looking around i'm just
looking around okay there's definitely
no security office over here
ooh
i wonder though
if
like if it'll let me i know i don't have
the objective for it
but if i go down to the daycare
to the the theater the theater under the
theater of your membership in the
daycare
i wonder if i go there now if i can get
that item then i wouldn't have to worry
about possibly screwing that section up
because that would
that was uh
that was close in there so if i can
avoid having to do that again i will
take it i will gladly take it because it
wasn't really like an objective that it
told me to go down and get that thing it
was just like a note that i found for
the maze so that i could flip the maze
properly
oh god you guys might have to sit
through me fiddling with the maze i
literally cut out 25 minutes of me
fiddling with that maze that's why i was
so aggravated when they almost got me
because there was just like so much
there
being freddie bunny
he doesn't need to be there
shut your faces
shush your faces
i don't need anybody anywhere except for
me and this gun
maybe
apparently not
come on get him oh my god
all right guys look listen listen i'm uh
i'm getting used to i was so used to no
scoping it that having this targeting
thing is fine
fine you know what fine we're here to be
completionist about it oh the lore you
guys and your lore you know you're
spoiled for the lore you guys knew
non-stop jabbering about the lore
oh the lord
you know you and your
incessant need for the lore what do you
think i do you think i'm matpat do you
think that's who i am no i'm here to
play
i let the plebs like him figure out the
meaning behind everything all i do is
charge forward into the darkness
because that's who i am that's what i do
i am the king here i have the crown i
say what goes and i'm only doing this
because i say it's happening so all of
you sit back and don't even try to
appreciate the magnificence that is my
mind
got him
can't say i didn't got him he didn't
catch me therefore i got him
all right hey freddie
see they obey they don't even care they
don't even try
they're too afraid of me
all right well he's here
i wonder if i bring him over here if
something will happen interesting
well would you look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
gregory what are you doing
i cannot see
i am your friend
why though
gregory what are you doing
uh
[Laughter]
he doesn't want to let me in anymore i'm
just too mean to him
he's really mad at me
he's not gonna let me in
oh man yeah no he don't want to let me
in anymore all right freddy fine
i can't get it
all right you too
you want some of this yeah that's what i
thought
now that i know to go for the eyes
wham what are you doing there
what are you doing
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership all right so
why
i cannot see
i don't know why that's funny to me oh
actually i know exactly why it's
hilarious okay
so
i now that i've wasted time listening to
you and you're in ain't blathering about
bloody bring freddie to the bowling
alley there's nothing there's nothing
and you have no idea what you're talking
about so that's the last time that i'm
gonna listen to you guys you don't know
what you're doing let me
handle things from now on
why don't you i know you're not really a
hands-on kind of viewer
why don't you sit back and let
an expert take over
all right
no no freddie's mad at me he don't want
to let me in anymore
no no no no freddie you don't want to
let me in anymore i made him mad so i've
officially broken that part of it
it's all good guys it's all good
it's all good don't even worry about it
don't even worry about it
don't worry your pretty little heads
[Music]
see i don't like the the zap in the eye
strategy it makes things too easy i'm
all for uh the the thrill of it i like
the the the bobbing and the weaving
feels like
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension remember
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
are you still mad at me
he's still mad at me i might have broken
i might have broken him freak
i might have really broken
i think
i think i might have broken him i think
i did hmm oh that's unfortunate for me
don't even think about it no oh i can't
run well this is unfortunate not fair
he must be cheating
must be must be cheating
oh this is super unfortunate
anyway all right i'm gonna go save now
now that it's thoroughly broken
it's okay it's okay it's okay guys all
right um daycare that's right that's
where i was going i forgot what i was
doing
i've gone the complete opposite
direction of where i'm going i'm just uh
having so much fun isn't there another
path over here i think it's either here
or yeah
so i think this will get me back
i believe
it's dork
i can't see
he's dork here
uh
maybe
i think possibly
yes yeah definitely well i wonder if
what if i zap myself with this
aha
i've fixed him
perfectly fixed now
done
i can't get out of him
i can't get out of him which means that
if i take him to the dance arcade he'll
be
he'll have to
[Laughter]
it's a perfect plan
oh boy i really did
i am the best
as really laggy
i am see this is why
i
wear the crown it's because no one can
play these games like i can i'm like neo
i see the code that lies between the
textures and the walls i see it all
as you never could my eyes are more open
than ever before
i tamper with the fabric of this reality
and everyone is just my plaything
my puppet if you will
i'm pulling the strings here
why don't you why don't you go and just
wait what why why don't you just go and
relax and let me
have my own little dance party
with
freddie i can't press the button oh i
can get out
oh i can get out
well
you're coming with me to the dance floor
my friend
you're gonna dance
i don't know if he was able to get here
and i think it just kicked me out
because he was like i'm not supposed to
be here
you're gonna dance buddy you're gonna
dance this guy's gonna dance
this guy's gonna dance i'm gonna make
him dance
oh i can't get him now okay that's fine
i want to see him dance
please tell me you can dance
please i'm begging you
i'm begging you
now that he's usable now
i fixed him see this is what i was
saying
i know this game is so well donated will
result in suspension of your money oh
hell
freddy please
freddie
freddie please freddie
do it do it freddy come on he's here the
music is bopping
freddy
please
dance
freddie come on come on freddy it's time
freddy come on
freddy please
dance for me
well anyway this guy's here so that's
nice let me shoot him in the eyes
that didn't work
all right freddy well your programming
error doesn't seem to work anymore so uh
well that's a damn shame
all right i hope you guys understand
that now that i have you trapped here i
am going to just dick around for about
10 hours now and all you can do is watch
also amy got me a christmas present
it's a mouse pad
so that's not my mouse but
thank you amy you're the best
oh
[Music]
all right i'm going back to bonnie bowl
okay yeah yeah i gotcha
i know that there's a lot of bugs right
there's a lot of bugs but at the same
time
i didn't have a bad time with it i mean
yeah it was aggravating at points but
and i'm not done with it right i know
i'm not done with the game uh but
it's one of those things where it has
charm no matter what because of the
universe that it is and what it's trying
to do i think it's like more ambitious
than it was able to execute on but that
doesn't mean it's bad like yeah there
are bugs but it hasn't really prevented
me from playing the game and it hasn't
made me stop wanting to play the game
you know so there's
there's just like a lot to it that i
enjoy
and and for all of my aggravations i
never at any point was like i don't like
this game
where'd he go
it is it is charming and it is
fun
and at times it is incredibly scary
because
she's
there you are
okay
so i'm gonna i'm gonna get in him before
i enter this place
okay calm down there buddy i know you're
excited
so yeah it's like for all of its bugs
and all of its quirks i just thoroughly
like it all right so i'm in freddy
in the bonnie bowl
i'm looking at this guy i'm over here
now
my power is about to run out which means
that i'm going to die
hello
i do not come up here anymore
i miss him
well that was nice
but i already knew that
i already knew that bonnie was gone and
all freddie would be all boo-hoo about
it because he's a big bubble-blowing
baby
that's just tampering with this is their
automated stuff that was not oh poor
freddie
oh whatever whatever a poor waste of my
time that's what i'm talking about
i know
bonnie's not here right now it's fine
we all know that bonnie is better than
monty that's apparent and obvious that
is incredibly
dad
freddie's a pet
freddy's like a like a stupid dog
freddy's a real real uh unintelligent
pet and uh that's about as far as the
relationship goes
you get called superstar one time and
you just let it go right to your head
nah
freddy uh freddy's um
freddy's not too bright let's just put
it that way whoa speaking of not too
they uh they're scared of me
they're too afraid
they can't handle what i'm offering
how did i get saved back i haven't hit
6am yet so that is how i am able to save
uh the arcade god or the the daycare you
guys need to stop distracting me i'm
doing official markiplier business here
very authentic very official very you
wouldn't understand it's really above
your pay grade knowing what uh goes on
in this brain
the genius that oozes out of me is just
so more than you could handle so don't
even bother just uh sit back and relax
you're on like freddy's level of
intelligence meanwhile i'm up here
with like
me intelligence
you wouldn't be able to handle what i'm
offering why don't you just go
i'm sorry stay please i'm sorry
i apologize it really like i get on a
live stream and i don't know what
happens to me i just i have an outlet
for all of my frustration and it's you
guys and i just i just can't help myself
wham boom
i just can't help myself
it just is
all right i'm just doing this so that i
can get the power i'm not gonna hide in
freddy because i'm not a coward
i'm just gonna
allow him to join me on this journey so
that i can uh let my own magnificence
shine
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry you're great you're
a superstar
hey
you're my superstar
got him works every time like a charm
eating out of the palm of my hand
oh god
that's their automated style
tampering then
automated staff will result
all right okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay you guys won't ever catch me being
nice ever again
i wouldn't dream of it i wouldn't dare
i couldn't possibly is there a security
office in here probably
tampering with fast there on a membrane
of your result in suspension of your
membership
okay
i'm willing to bet
that i can
get this thing
because why wouldn't i right it's not
like they're gonna despawn that item or
something like that probably whoa
that was
you orbited way sooner than i thought
you would
well good thing i saved
where are you oh you're right behind me
that's problem
i meant to go up the stairs oh listen
you don't have to
he listens to reason he does not listen
to reason distraction
why is moon mad
all right it's fine guys it's fine look
didn't i tell you how amazing and
handsome i was
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will reward him
of your membership
suspension of this membership
i was looking the wrong way guys it
turns out i was looking the wrong way
freddy get your ass over here
ready where's freddy
freddy redman fritzer
freddy boy
ready boy friend man
oh you guys just lovely
there he is
ready
get your butt down here
get your big metal butt down here
i better be pretty ready there he is
come here boy come here come here come
here oh who's a good freddy
oh that's a good boy
that's a good boy
all right let's see
well convenient safe glad i have this
here and i'm able to utilize it and it
looks like the item that i need is right
there
hmm interesting
do i not even need the party pass
oh i forgot about that whole deal
hi bud
hey
lemmy and you
i forgot about the whole deal with
the
you can't hurt me i'm in freddy
i forgot about the whole deal with the
vent after you go in the vent
do you just fight monty and then
you go down to the gulf area
then you just go
then you just go welcome to freddy
fazbear's fazbear theater now enjoy the
comedy stylings of staff
why is it saying that now
stat bot
you lied to me
you lied don't lie
but i think
am i crazy yes answers yes so much yes
but also i have good ideas i'm auntie
hey what's going on buddy hey working
hard hardly working yes a lap all right
yeah you keep it up there pal you keep
it up there keep the spirits up
ah man you hurt my hand on that ass yeah
have you been doing the jazzercise the
mazer size i know you always keeping up
anyway
it's time to go i gotta go
i gotta go guys i gotta go
you didn't see nothing usually i would
cut all this nonsense out you shush
all right so what i'm gonna do now is
i'm gonna go see if i can take care of
uh monty
before even getting in golf because if
i'm not mistaken
i have a path
to
go there
unless i'm some kind of crazy
probably not
[Music]
maybe
i have no idea
[Music]
ah
i'm actually so much happier that this
is going this way than it was that i
thought it was gonna be i thought it was
going to be like an arduous journey of
trial and error error with like
with like hours in between each attempt
i thought it was going to be like
unbelievably
arduous and difficult this is fun this
is what i love about this game this is
like i'm just running around doing my
thing
having fun zapping eyeballs oh bamboo
boy bam
you're lucky
you're not lucky anymore
they don't want to mess
i'm wondering if actually like am i
actually hitting them
in their body and then they can't scan
me anymore but they keep moving for some
reason
pampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership oh i don't have that right
right i don't ow
wait
oh
right okay all right i get it okay i do
need the party pass because i get the
party pass four mazer size in the golf
area
okay fine tampering with fashion
stuff will result in suspension of your
memory fine
fine it's fine it's fine
fine
bam okay so what i'm gonna do now is i
think it's time to
i don't know if there's anything else
that i can do just yet i've been to the
fascade i've been to the prize counter i
got that i've been to bonnie bowl
no that's that area over there i
haven't been there yet but i'll be there
i don't
i don't think there's anything else i
can do
because i can't get to the
mazer size controls yet because i can't
get in there i don't have a party pass
yet
that's already done i don't know why
that's still doing the thing
maybe i bugged that out
upgrade freddy
mystery mix that's done okay
that's done done done
done
okay
i think it's time to do the arduous
thing that i just said i didn't have to
do
it's time
it's time everybody
it's time to go get this done oh hey
roxy
no
no no no no
well you missed me so
kind of stupid on your part
anyway
all right see around pal
see you around friend
all right so i'm gonna go upgrade freddy
i'm not gonna screw that up i'm gonna
save right here
i'm gonna go down there
and then
yeah
that'll be it i think
i think let me just double check
there's got to be something else right
there's got to be something else that i
could do
princess quest
i do remember that yeah there was
something about princess quest i i found
princess quest too
i was a machine somewhere in the
building actually i could see this
yeah i found princess quest 2
that was in the the arcade and the other
one no that was a there was a different
game
monty golf
arcade
it was in the daycare right
it was yeah it was
okay
that's something to do because i'd
rather do all of this nonsense with the
exploring around
you know
when i can save that's what i would
rather do tampering with so let me go to
the daycare again suspension of your
membership and try that out
because
i have a funny feeling
i i knew that there was something up
with the princess quest like why have a
specific note for that right why have a
specific note
there's got to be something with those
arcade games i didn't know what you
could do with the arcades before but
there's got to be something to do with
that arcade game right
so
there's got to be something to do
i think anyway
[Music]
okay
it's in roxy raceway wait
was it i remember seeing it there
was it there
okay i'm trusting you on this one i'm
trusting you but this is the last time
that i'm gonna trust you this is the
last time i'm gonna trust you it's the
last time
and then i'm turning chat off and i'm
not even gonna look at you i'm not even
gonna listen to you i'm not gonna not
even give you a bit of attention
all right
no no no no i'm not even looking at chad
anymore i never do anyway
your thoughts interfere with my genius
so i'm going to make do
okay
nah
right so i think uh the raceway over
there
roxy is just being annoying i think i
left yeah i have this here might as well
grab these things that i can find while
i can find them
oh that's useful
don't know what that's for
but it's useful maybe
all right so somewhere in the raceway is
another arcade game oh
my god
all right thank you
wait
what oh i gotta go up for it that's
right because it's all broken down
okay
so i'm going here
you've interfered enough
haven't you done enough
the answer is no you have not because
you haven't listened to distractible yet
hey
there's a link down in the description
that goes to my podcast with my good
friends bob and wade where we have a
great time just chatting about utter
nonsense and for about an hour
at a time you're gonna love it click the
link in the description below that says
listen to distractible pick your
favorite podcasts and streaming site and
go check it out see this is the benefit
of live streams
you can't skip this
you gotta
you can't escape it you can't escape me
all right anyway i'm going here
nah nah hush your faces ha shop
you hush
i don't want to hear none of it oh
there's something in the information
over there i didn't go over there
go to
distractiblepodcast.com which is a
questionable website that probably
exists
definitely 100
certainly exists where is the raceway
where am i
ah this is it but i don't have i don't
have an icon anymore but that's fine who
needs it okay so there
probably is something
down here in one of these side rooms to
the garage
maybe
uh there was like a present here that i
found i don't know if there's anything
else yeah i found that one
okay
it says there's another room right there
i finally have my my icon again there's
another room like back around that
corner let me try that
like around here
other side of the stairs oh it's like
chained off
interesting
what's back there
huh
maybe there's something maybe it's not
probably not though
no just a bunch of laundry bins
some
radioactive chemical barrels
stuff like that
oh there's something over here
oh
out of order okay
interesting
oh hey bell what are you doing there no
no no
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership huh
well this is odd i feel like there would
be something here there's a helmet there
but i don't think that's something
no
i feel like there would be something
here
never stop smiling no hang in there i am
shut up oh this thing
oh he's coming here
he's common
got it
roxy's weakness find a brick
oh
of course of course ah
[Music]
oh
suddenly runner over with a car you say
i will take that into great hand and
thought of that hmm
what a unique idea
i see i see
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership okay okay okay all right so
i'm not seeing anything here
i don't know of anything over there
i don't know what's going on here there
anywhere
i don't even know if i can get up there
anymore but that would be another area
i think i might be blocked off
no yes yes no yes that's blocked off
maybe there's another way to get up
there
hmm
i doubt it
get zapped all right don't get zapped
all right i'll miss every shot
that was a warning
don't make me get serious
go under nah okay so i can't go up there
this way was just back where i
absolutely annihilated roxy
and uh i don't think there's anything
else here
no that just goes down that's where i
got out of the area there
[Music]
okay nothing here
you guys are saying the salon like i
know what that means
oh the salon yeah of course the salon
i don't know what that is oh definitely
100 know what that is
i've definitely been there and have that
knowledge see not all of us just look up
other videos to get the answers some of
us actually enjoy the game and play it
thoroughly and the thrill of the hunt is
the only thing that they we need to
continue on our journey to greatness
but no you look it up on a wiki site or
another guide or something like that no
you don't know you don't have the stones
necessary to dig deep and search for the
truth and see it with your own naked
eyes
while you're also naked i am naked right
now
you don't understand
you don't understand true commitment
to the truth
and finding it
you have no
idea anyway all right i'm gonna go
i'll see all around here this was a big
waste of my life
what a useless pile of nothing
okay
all right
let's do a thing
let's actually be
proactive about this
i'm thinking
of a number between one and a hundred
and if you guess it correctly i will
give you a hug
so start guessing
oh someone's getting close not quite
i'll try again
oh good guess good guess but no
ah you almost had that one it was very
close
no no no no not that one not that one no
good guess though good guess
yeah oh you'd think that you'd think it
would be that number but funnily enough
no
no no no no no oh there's a charging
thing here
all right keep going you're almost out
of time you better get your guesses in
or you don't want to miss out on the hug
oh almost there
you almost got it
ah time's up oh i'm sorry guys time is
up
i apologize
oh you were so close you were right
there oh no no no i'm not going to tell
you the number i'm not going to tell you
the number but you were close
you were real close yeah you were this
close away from it you almost got it
though hey
you may not get a hug but you know what
you do get
you get to listen to a great podcast
called distractible it's one that i made
with my good friends bob you can listen
to it on any of your favorite podcasting
sites spotify apple podcast the other
ones
why don't you go check it out that's a
good consolation prize if you ask me
almost as good as getting that hug maybe
even better you know listening to it is
like having your ears hugged
by me anyway
congratulations
i am lagging a lot
i'm back now literally uh youtube didn't
like me
the i i the collective groaning of
everyone after that
was so loud that it shook the internet
and you
wasn't able to keep up with any of it
i think i'm back now anyway
all right
yeah yeah yeah i know lag yeah yeah yeah
so
can i slide in freddy can freddie slide
down here
freddie you wanna
freddie you wanna go for a slide
you wanna go for a slide pal
doll so close
that's fine guys it's fine don't worry
about it it's totally fine hush
security oh hi
security
um audio's cutting out
but it's not muted it's i have no idea
what is it what does it sound like hang
on one second
hmm no idea what is it what is the sound
that's fine it just needed to catch up a
bit you guys you guys and your
your just refresh or whatever it's fine
anyway that was so worth it
so worth going down that slide i'm so
glad i did that but anyway i'm gonna go
downstairs um because i think there
actually is there's like a back area
here
i know there's a lot of goodies here
that i have not obtained but i'm not
worried about that right now i'll worry
about that
if i have to worry about that not
and not any moment sooner
okay
yeah if you're having issues uh yeah my
internet like is hiccuping but it's fine
just uh restart
refresh the browser what is going on
there
i don't know why that's there
uh yeah there's this whole back area
here what is this
what is going on there
what is that
that's not the basement because the
theater's over there and that leads
yeah that leads down there what is this
what's this area hang on it's like
behind these bathrooms
i don't know if there's any way to get
in there
no
a golden toilet
guys
guys it's a golden
it's a golden toilet guys
guys
the truth of the lord
really reaching now
okay
so not there
maybe through the gift shop how do you
get
no that's the top entrance to the
theater that's not what i'm looking for
this just leads back here
i don't think that there's anything
there
yeah i don't think so but whatever oh
yeah that was that old poster that i
found and then lost because i died
before i could when i couldn't save and
it was all useless yeah how do you get
back there
that's interesting maybe one of those
rooms up there does have a back way
hmm maybe
i don't think so
that's a tv
hmm
i'm not seeing any way to get back there
but anyway you guys said that there was
princess
quest 2 here somewhere but i'm not
seeing it
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership i don't remember seeing it on
my
journey here before
zoom in on the map how
how
i wish i could you know i wish i could
i've never been able to figure out how
to do that you know
never really
never really got that one
i you know
i would love to zoom in on this map
this map doesn't have as much
functionality as i would have thought
but alas i must persevere regardless
one second
come back come on i got you before come
on
come on
come on there we go
off ready mask great well here's the
behind the ticket counter
that doesn't hear
all right
yeah whatever
who needs it i don't think it would be
over here
now enjoy the comedy
i don't know
i don't know who's got time for that not
me
okay
i'm gonna stop putting around i'm gonna
stop putting around
time to get serious
what's over here i don't think i've ever
been over here
markiplier is matpat
maybe in another universe
maybe
maybe but in this one
i just play who put some generators
hello
what did i get what i got
bb world game has been acting up
customers have complained that it starts
to glitch over time i headed to the
theater to fix it and now it's gone i
never saw a move request so it should
still be somewhere ah i guess i'll check
again after the company meeting
interesting
there's no record of a pq3 arcade yet
there is a cabinet tucked away in phasor
blast won't work though
princess quest three sometimes i hear it
in attract mode but i've never seen a
single image displayed too creepy leave
it where it is at least until i play one
and two
ah
ha ha
ha ha ha
ha
okay
so there was
a
some heavy cables there was
a princess quest
one
here
does that mean it got moved down to the
basement where all those
animatronics are and if so it would have
been really useful if i'd
looked for it before i got all those
red light green light the squid game
robots uh
activated
so maybe
there's no lag in my mic you gotta
restart refresh if it's lagging you have
to refresh it's the only way about it
because everything seems normal to
normal to me and if i listen to myself
refresh it's the only way
yeah exactly so if you're having trouble
please refresh and it should sync all
back up for you
immediately
i don't know
if for certain
it's gonna work out this way
i'm thinking let me just grab this
i'm thinking
that if it were anywhere in this place
it would definitely be down below
that is a pretty small
patrol window
okay
damn it
tampering with fazbear
automated i know this probably isn't
going to be good for me
but
alas
at least i have saves here
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
now
are you guys still down here
but you're still done okay you're
you're sleeping down there
you guys are sleeping that's good
i don't see any arcade cabin there some
backup generators to put into the
children's play tubes
you know
for uh
breathing
can i get in there no damn that would be
fun
caution safety glasses required why
but why though
but why
maybe
down here somewhere
this back room
no
whoa
that stain looks weird
i don't remember seeing it down here
before i feel like i would have seen an
arcade but i guess i oh that's weird
i guess i didn't really look too
carefully everywhere
it's entirely possible
but not entirely plausible
no i definitely didn't see it down here
that's okay
yeah nothing
okay
so it's not down here i've officially
eliminated that as a possibility
so where could it be
i know there's a princess maker or
princess quest in uh
[Music]
in uh
the the dj hallway where the giant thing
was like
exploding down the hallway at me where
everything was collapsing
yeah
i know there's that
i don't know if that was princess quest
one
or princess quest
uh
two i thought it was two
i think it was two
wasn't it
yeah that was princess quest two
that was two
so i've looked through here and all
these places
that was two that was definitely two i
do know that and it said that there was
a princess quest
one here at some point but it got moved
which means that it
would probably be in the back room of
some other place somewhere else i just
don't know where you keep saying roxy's
salon
i don't know where roxy's salon is i've
never seen a roxy's salon
you say roxy's raceway i was just in
there and then you kept saying salon
i don't know what any of that means also
it's very warm in here so i'm going to
crack the window i apologize
in any way noisy
oh my goodness
okay
so i got power there i don't need to be
ready right now
yeah it it also could be a thing that i
can't get to them because i don't have
the last upgrade for freddy which i
can't get until i get the other party
pass unless there's some other secret
way
into the golf course but i don't think
there is besides
because this is the golf course i no is
that the golf course it might be i don't
know uh there's no other way into the
golf course besides
the vent system
in mazer size
i don't believe anything what is this
level three
i think that's the golf course yeah it
is it is that's the golf course that's
definitely the golf
course so
i think i got a
i gotta bite the bullet
it's time
to
make life difficult for myself but it's
okay because i'm good at this game and
i'm
i'm okay
it's all good
i can do this because one i'm gonna do
this i have i don't need to go to the
theater for the
the the the maze pass
i go right into
monty's golf course i do all that
nonsense yadda yadda yee bitty ubity
hibbetty hobbity boom
the salon is next to the raceway don't
tell me these things
don't say things like that that gets my
hope up
you don't want my hobo
don't get my hope up i don't think i can
can i get to it though that's the thing
because there are like chain-link fences
right
all right i'm gonna check one more time
because i thoroughly comb that whole
place and i couldn't find anything you
said next to
roxy's raceway you said next to
yes you can
okay
all right i'm trusting you
but if i if you if you're wrong about
this if you're wrong about this
i'm gonna literally punch you in your
nose when you sleep
so you better be careful you better be
sure this is gonna happen to you
you better watch out
you better not cry
i know when you're sleeping why is this
one yellow
why is this one not accessible
the golden pram it's the golden pram
everyone
the lore
all right whatever
but go
is there another door
are you telling me that there is another
door
telling me that there is another door
here
where i currently am
is that what you're telling me
because then it's not in roxy's raceway
is it
it's not in the raceway
interesting
looks like someone is getting punched in
the teeth
while you sleep hope you sleep well
tonight
because a punch is in store for you
oh
ah
oh look at this
never seen this before in my life
huh
funny this
new area
really interesting here
really interesting stuff
hmm
fascinating
all right i'll be right there i i know
it's probably over there but i'm just
exploring this area or have i been here
before i did go here no yes no i don't
remember did i yes i think maybe
possibly i definitely did can i get
through there
huh no
wide blockades
even think about it
you can't see nothing
oh hello
bam
hello
i don't think i've been here before have
i been here before wham
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership uh-huh oh there it is hang on
one second
hold on hold on more important things
this definitely important message
i did it i did what you wanted i beat
parts one and two why won't you turn on
what else is there tell me
i don't know man i don't know okay so
wait let me save just in case like this
is gonna be a game over thing where's
the save station and why would i check
the map it would never tell me
gotta be a savior right
oh handy
hey that's handy
warning tampering with fazbear server
will result in suspension of your mouse
the last time i saved i don't even
remember
oh
yeah there are a lot of you warning
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result there's no save here
membership where's the save
there's no save
ah whatever it can't have been that long
i'm gonna go for it first drive
tampering with fast fare automated staff
will look at me extension of your
membership oh okay well
what's the last time i said it doesn't
matter
it's fine i'm not worried you worried
yeah i'm not worried it's all good all
right
oh
[Music]
what the hell is this
interesting
fascinating
what can i do
i can't do anything
oh it's left click because of course it
is
how nice
interesting oh uh
okay that's a little weird
man this whoop
hey pal
hey you don't need to do that
all right this is whiskey oh it's on my
head
i'm fine
all right easy enough
[Music]
oh a small key this must be oh this must
open something of well that's a problem
i hate that that's not good
well i'm just gonna mosey on over this
way don't mind me say pals i must do ow
my nog how's my all right
okay hey pals how you doing why does it
feel like the binding of isaac
all right well yeah
well don't mind me
lighting up the place well you're you
guys are kind of quick oh god no not
like this not like this
don't don't don't
[Music]
nailed it i am the greatest
come to me
ah easy scrubs terrible terrible
terrible
you're all terrible well i can't get
over there
oh there's lag
i don't know my internet sucks here
i apologize if there's lag oh
oh that is a problem
and dodging weave
oh god
well can't find any other light to light
okay
that's a problem
this is indeed a problem this is what
you would call a problem
is there a light here anywhere anywhere
any light will do i would love a light
that's not a light but i'll take it
that's health good
light light light no light no light no
lights no light no light lights are not
light no no light oh there's no lights i
just needed to go
okay
wait before i do anything this looks
like a code
okay
i feel strange
stronger
there's definitely a code
okay this is definitely one
two
this looks like it has one missing
so i'm willing to bet this is three
this would be four then
nope oh i was wrong
okay one two three uh okay
nope
okay
i bet this
ah then this would be four and this
would be fine
okay that was easy
okay
good
this looks weird a strange key i wonder
what it opens maybe that strange door
that i just saw over here
oh
wow this looks good
uh
okay
oh
great
i can't read that
um
oh i'm back
okay
all right
well i did that
that's good
so
now i go do princess quest two right
warning tampering right bear automated
staff that's what i do suspension of
your membership
warning tampering with you
i definitely will result in suspension
of your membership
all right okay
easy enough
yeah it's probably something to do with
um
i don't know the lore i'll make
conclusions later you guys don't spoil
nothing i'm not even looking at chat
anymore because it don't matter i'm
gonna go play princess quest 2 which i
believe was in the fascade
not this way
it was in like the uh the dance party
way in the back of that thing was
princess quest 2. i did find princess
quest 3 at some point
i don't think
i don't think i remember where
specifically though but i know that i
saw it because i remember seeing him be
like oh look princess quest three that's
interesting i know i saw it at some
point i know i did
hey i can save
wow look at me
look at me
all right so let's go find
the
second one
which was up here
oh well he's bugged out it don't matter
oh
what
freddy
did you break the elevator for me did
you break the elevator
come over here step away from the
elevator
there we go okay i don't think he was
supposed to be able to come up here and
i somehow broke him into here yeah
all right
so when i do this one
and i beat this one handily easily
because there's amateur level stuff here
then we're going to get another piece of
lore
and then we can start to piece it all
together but i'm willing to bet that
there's other arcade games because
that's what this was talking about there
was like
csf
chica feeding frenzy
there's other games
to play
and you gotta play them
all probably before you'll get to
princess quest three
that's the tricky bit
well all right
that just doesn't work anymore
oh do you now oh do you now oh you do
now oh you actually do okay uh
hey there's no need
there's no need oh boy oh boy oh yeah
chica you're still here no oh god you
don't slow down why don't you
hang on now
and wait wait wait
okay we're good
probably good probably fine we're
probably fine
probably fine let's see i'm super glad
i'm doing this while i can save
sure would be stressful if i wasn't able
to do that
oh i'm out of laser
okay
let me get this save in here
hi
hi friend
all right
save in here
and then
easy peasy easy breezy pizza
easy peasy breezy
let's oh what the hell
flip flop cop
weird okay
whatever i don't even think i could get
through that even if i had the claw
upgrade
oh freddie is here
hey fred
how you doing pal you stick around just
in case i got a funny feeling something
bad's gonna happen
okay
princess quest 2
easy enough
enter
oh you are alive that is good take the
sword of light and go
well at least i can fight back
all right whoa
hi y'all
come at me bruce
no no
all right well this is easier
yeah yeah yeah
wow okay maybe not
oh
three hits to kill him
chump level stuff
easy peasy
oh wow how nice if only i didn't get
hurt
i stopped
as much as people might think i'm not as
up on the lore of five nights at
freddy's as people might think
but i do know some things right
i know that at some point
like in relation to
[Music]
baby from sister location
there was a whole thing about the
daughter
and i'm wondering if that's who this
princess is in this game
right
something about that
yeah the lore i let the
the others do the oh god
bullet hell all right well maybe i can
kill these guys
i can yes i can
oh god ow
okay okay that's enough out of you
that's enough out of you
that's out that's enough
out
okay
you there we go
uh one more
uh everyone just wants to play with me
there we go
all right anymore anyone else anyone
else want to tussle
with the muscle
all right so that's open there but
what's over here i see
okay ow
god you suck
not today
i gotta i gotta gauge the distance on
the sword because it's very small
out and let's step on some geometry
there bam okay what am i playing
ah rogue legacy here
what is this feeling my heart grew three
sizes this day
yeah oh no
come on
i know it's gonna get dicier as i go on
i know this isn't terribly difficult but
bear with me i'm just trying to be
methodical and careful so that i don't
have to do it again because i'm tired of
replaying things
and also i remember i did find an arcade
game for chica's feeding frenzy in the
bakery there was like this bakery that
had the big cupcake oven i went in there
and i did see that i forget what episode
that was but it was a while back when i
was just exploring around
so there's got to be something there
that you do after you play these two
because it must be you play these two
and then there's more
right that's what it must be it must be
thus
what is over here oh no that's the way i
came okay
right
yeah if if the audio is lagged out just
uh refresh the browser it'll all sync
back up
no i came from that way
so maybe i didn't go that way let me see
what's up here first
oh no this is the beginning area
huh well i have the key am i done
why is that red
oh
interesting
okay
uh that wasn't too difficult
i
don't don't
don't don't don't
i'm waiting for it to get like super
bullet hell and have like 10 000 of
these all shooting at once
oh
now
oh not my nog
thank you very much
damn you
damn you all
if you're confused as to what's
happening yes this is still security
breach if you're just joining me i just
so happen to be doing some side stuff
while i can still save
i'm probably gonna help me unlock the
true ending or whatnot
i heard something over here
oh it must have been this
okay
handy
more health but why
must be for the scrubs who are bad at
this game
i know if these shadows have anything to
do with bonnie being decommissioned i
wonder if it all has to do with bonnie
being decommissioned like what's with
the bunnies that's what i gotta ask
myself is like what's with the ah here
we go
i see
i
see interesting
okay
fascinating
huh
all right puzzle
oh i just gotta do it one at a time
oh
interesting
wait how does that help me
how does that help me wait how does it
help me
[Music]
hold on no one tell me no one tell me
okay that moves both of them
this moves just this one
so
is this what it's supposed to be
no
oh
all right family congratulations your
quest is done time to sleep oh
well what about this door
oh oh
why was she
in a security office that probably if i
was able to go back in my brain and look
at it
was probably the same office as five
nights at freddy's one
what was that all about
hello the law ring the lore alarms
everyone
bring the lore alarms
all right okay so we got that lore
which is good
i love lore we all love lore who doesn't
love lore you know what else is good for
lore distractible it's my podcast with
bob and waves link's in the description
if you don't click on the link and
listen to it i will find you and hunt
you down
and make you listen
i'll do it
i'll do it okay so are you coming this
way
so now that i have that
i think there is definitely something to
do with the other arcade games
that i've found
and have messages about like chica's
feeding frenzy which is in the
bakery or whatever it is
oh don't get me
it's in like the bakery or something
right
i'm fine cause gregory's secretly a
robot
not really human after all
yeah so i'm gonna go i'm gonna go look
at that i don't really remember where it
is but i'm gonna go try to find that so
that hopefully i can have some kind of a
guess of whether or not that's correct
because i have these messages
these messages of like um
cheeks feeding frenzy in the bakery
won't turn off keeps running there's no
way bbworld uh headed here to fix this
now it's gone okay so it's not there
anymore
check after the company meeting why is
monty golf arcade in the mini golf
course makes absolutely no sense it
seems to work okay otherwise so that's
in the mini golf course i can't get
there yet but at least i know where
roughly where the feeding frenzy game is
i think it was um
i think it was like accessible down one
of the hallways that i went i don't
really remember which one or where i was
going but it was when i was lost and i
went down a hallway and i didn't know
where i was and i kind of just went in
circles but maybe
ah you're all right stop complaining
um was it down that hallway
it might have been down this hallway
this hallway
this one
maybe no it's out of order do you get
here
how do you get here
no idea hmm
i don't even know where that goes don't
don't
you're gonna get zapped warning
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in a look at the map
remember because okay that doesn't go
anywhere
apparently that's completely closed off
which is fine
that's the arcade upstairs there's
probably something up there to be
perfectly honest but i'm not gonna look
there just yet
okay
how do i get down i need to get down i
need to get down where's the down
where's it down
here's the down okay so i go here
come on oh let me do a sweet move at
least
fine
you looking and pointing tampering with
the fazbear automated staff will result
in suspension
that leads to that cove thing
that there's no other entrance here
there's a way back through these doors
seem to be out of order apparently are
they actually yes they are
i thought that was way back here
hmm
wasn't there
i was able to get back here
yeah i know vani's room i can't get
there shush shush your face i'm not
going for princess quest three shush you
don't know what you're talking about
because you don't understand my genius
i'm sorry are you the king of five
nights at freddy's i didn't think so
me
i will take over from here allow me to
show you the magnificence that is the
things that i am capable of doing which
is so many incredible things
all right anyway yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's not what i'm going for
you uh you wouldn't understand the steps
that is required to really appreciate
this
[Music]
that's okay i i get it you know
i understand
i understand i can put myself in your
shoes
i know i'm going the complete wrong way
but i'm just trying to find where the
hell this other place was
okay
so
yeah where did i go to get to that thing
i don't even remember
where was that
i don't think it was down here i i
really don't think it was connecting
down here but i'm just exploring because
i feel like it
where does this go this goes to that
like broken down cafeteria what was this
all about
this was strange when i first came here
i was very confused
because it just seemed like a completely
ramshackled destroyed
don't ask why animatronics why
animatronics i'm asking
yeah but why did monty just go on a
rampage down here or did something else
happen entirely
must have been something else that went
down here
i know this is where i found like the
golden chica so it's like super lower
place like extreme lore
100 lore
can get down here at least i don't know
if he has any insight here
oh
stupid
yeah i already got this
i don't know if there'd be anything else
here and i don't see like an arcade
cabinet or something so i think i'm good
here
this is clear
okay
so check that off the list i don't think
that there's anything else that would be
down there
where does this go
where am i
oh it's the
this is the last place that i want to be
i definitely oh
okay
yeah there's definitely nothing here and
i don't want to be here because i hate
this place forever i hate this place
forever
so that's what this was i see and that
popped out here of all places it did but
why if this didn't let me go back up am
i crazy
i am
i am absolutely crazy i am 100 crazy
okay and then there's a chain-link fence
here that i can slash through
but i've been here before i've been
there before and there was something
back there
there was i remember
i remember now
i remember i remember there was
something back here
there was
something that
peaked to my interest that raised an
eyebrow
there was not there nothing
what was it back here that peaked
my interest
and why
nope it's all the laundry room never
mind i'm an idiot i am wrong and this is
stupid and i shouldn't be here and why
would i be here in the first place
maybe something back there
cold storage
this is where i was trying to
find the generator to shut chica down
okay
i don't think this is gonna help me much
but it is here
okay nothing else all right we're good
here
i think i've cleared the whole area i
think i can get out of here
so that's exactly what i'm gonna do
okay okay okay i can cross all of this
off the list
now for good so
i need to find where the hell that
bakery was
i have no idea that's so strange that i
can't even remember where that was
[Music]
yeah i know i need the claws for a lot
of things there's probably some areas
that are just completely inaccessible
without me getting those claws
so i think it might be time for me to
finally do that
hmm
interesting
is there's something over there
i don't think so no nothing
nothing over there
but there might be something over here
through here
other side of this place
huh
ah out of order okay fine
fine you win
you win
okay
i'm just gonna go for it it's time i've
putzed around enough
i've lolly gagged
it's time to upgrade freddie get to the
end so that i can go into the golf
course get the claws and then i won't be
bashing my head against the wall trying
to find things that i may not be able to
find
i'm not nowhere
where are you nowhere
nowhere
and i'm pretty sure at this point in the
game that i'm good enough that i won't
die randomly from the craziest stuff
unless i'm very dumb
i don't think i can do anything at all
so i'm gonna
save here
run freddy all the way back to the
entrance
stay in the place
continue onwards
and then
get
monty broke
to and back
and then finally
let me just make sure freddy has full
charge he do he do you do he do you do
okay he do he do he do 540 long 540
let me go save here because from this
point on this will be the last time that
i'm able to save
i know that for a fact but i don't think
that i'm going to die again because i'm
pretty sure
that i have everything that i need
okay
welcome to parts and service preparing
for upgrade procedure now if i can just
not die on this side of the cylinder
once i get the claws i'm not worried
about failing right you begin by
removing freddie's face
freddie's nose to remove skull housing
if you press the nose too soon it will
fail you which is good to know carefully
detach the ocular connector
all right
i'm actually going to click them right
you guys are helping me remember right
you better that's why you're here
pressure's on everybody
pressure's on great plug the replacement
eyes into the open eye sockets
well done reattach the ocular connector
wires
it is time to close the faceplate
commence testing phase
all right we're good we're good this is
easy this is the easy part
no stress it's amazing how different the
pressure is when i know from now on that
it's like
game over if i died and i know i have
not died this entire time like i'm aware
of that
okay yeah i know that i know that uh
like i haven't died this entire time
maybe maybe i have once but i don't
think i have because
i've literally been goofing around and
that's how always out is when i'm
relaxed and i'm no stressed no problem
never a problem in the world
i'm having a hard time adjusting uh-huh
you look different to me different
i can see movement through the walls
really i didn't know roxy could see
through walls he's on roxy's eyes
yeah
there was an accident in the raceway is
she okay
well
nothing seems to stop
the daycare attendant is loose one last
time uh-huh
that's great oh i didn't charge my
flashlight that's fine come on freddy
these eyes are amazing
there are wondrous colors and objects i
never knew existed nothing can hide from
me now nothing get over here freddy oh
what
oh it's not letting me go up this oh you
oh you
is it now maybe that was the bug i could
have sworn that before i was able to go
right up oh
you a hole
you a-hole
oh that's annoying that's very annoying
all right but i know the way the i know
the other way back i can make it
i think
it's always gotta do some
it's always gotta mess with me somehow
but it's no problem
it's all fine i can make it it's just a
little bit of a longer way
it's fun
it's totally fine
[Music]
god that takes so long all right let's
go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
again let's go gang
this way i don't know okay
easy peasy easy peasy easy peasy
i haven't seen moon man
i know he's gonna pop up at any moment
it's weird not having moon man here
oh god six minutes come on well six
quote unquote minutes
time stands still for so long
it's like being in the north pole in the
polar express
all right just got to get to the
elevator bam boom i'm out
easy peasy easy peasy easy peasy easy
easy peasy stay with me easy peasy
everybody it's easy and it's peasy it's
peasy easy it's easy peasy easy peasy
peas are easy the easiest peas you've
ever seen easy peasy
easy peasy
easy peas
okay no no no it's not no it's not
yeah good night do you know what time it
is uh the doors are open
why are you still here easy people do
you plan on moving in or you just want a
job
maybe join the internship program
you would make a great security guard
gregory
i think you deserve a reward
go check the main stage no
[Music]
here's a piece of easy peasy easy piece
of the piece of ease and these pieces
these pieces of piece of ease in the
pieces and the these peas and peas are
easy
easy peasy baby easy peasy the peas is
the easiest easiest i will come back
soon actually i'm not going to leave so
shush
shishman's shishman's
easy peas
no
i cannot exit this facility
of course you can come on we can hide
you somewhere
without a recharge station
my systems would shut down within an
hour
it is a safety precaution
it is
my design
this is where i must stay
do not return
it will never be safe
i will miss you freddie
if i leave now
nothing will change will it
there will be more disappearances
ah yes
i am afraid that is correct it is
correct gregory you have a choice to
make i know i'm staying
thank you for the past i'll take this
i am glad i found this party pass there
are areas we have not investigated
you're running away superstar thank you
i will lead the way if you let me go i'm
gonna go i've already done the vanity
ending what are you talking about go
watch my videos you're not real fans if
you don't know that i've already done it
you
guys don't understand the magnificence
that is my ability to play this game
i am
unmatched
there is no equal when it comes to me
and my abilities
it's incredible really outstanding
anyway like favorite confidence crime
whatever
his favoriting even still a thing on
i've asked that before i've never double
checked
i don't think it is well maybe it is
no idea
if you get like youtube
premium i think you can download them at
least whatever it's not important i've
got something to investigate over in
monty golf
monty i have a bone to pick with you oh
god oh
i have to be careful now i actually have
to be careful
death is permanent
i mean death is permanent in other cases
too but i'm just saying in this
particular case therefore would be quite
permanent for me that i would have to
redo it which i know isn't exactly
permanent but
let's not split hairs here
it's all fine
it was down this way
that's where it was
it was this way
on everybody i've got a mission
i remember now
i remember
everybody hold on
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
right here
this is it
this is the place where it all began
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership right here
it was here
chica's feeding frenzy was right here
don't you remember
everybody
it was right here
right here
and there's nothing i can do with it so
whatever i guess i can't actually do
anything with that but that was fun at
least i knew that it was there just had
to make sure that i wasn't crazy
which i'm not
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result it's all good it's all
fine it's all fine it's all fine it's
all fine guys don't worry about that now
i go to the golf course
and then when i'm at the golf course i
can
do
something i can't play golf i know that
but i'll be able to do something
hey
take a party pass there you go bill
all right thank you
more elevators to wait on
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna get uh i'm gonna get the
uh
[Music]
all right
so we're going here i can't say
i need to go back whoa hey pal
those guys seem a bit more forgiving
than they have in the past i don't know
why
okay
oh level 10
right wait whoa
not me
no
you are a douchebag
you're a curious
you might want to look around that
innocence that's the black light upgrade
oh my god are you kidding me
oh my god and you're blind oh you're
blind you're blind you're blind
they know you are here get the security
upgrade and get out
size
it's fine
got everything i needed everything's
totally fine
we're not gonna
talk about what just happened we're not
gonna talk about it
we're not gonna what's this
use the camera flash to stun the other
animatronics
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
what a relaxing game
what a lovely day
lovely time
with lovely people
okay now why
why
don't
oh you do not do not
don't why
why would you do this why are you like
this
why are you like this
stop being like this
are you serious
all right we're all good hey we made it
good great all's good that can end good
well
that was low stress and great it's
amazing how once i uh can't save anymore
everything just goes weird
strange strangest things happen anyway
three oh look at
i swear i pressed three before when i
first got it and it did not work i swear
to you i pressed three before and it
didn't work
i swear
i pressed three before and it did not
work
but now it works
great good that's exactly what i wanted
to happen
i wanted it to be that way
good
okay
so now that i have this i'm gonna go up
to mazer size and then i'm gonna
rearrange the maze so i can go into the
vent and then i'm gonna do the final uh
monty confrontation and then i'm gonna
be able to uh kill him and then i'll be
able to uh take his hands
and then all we'll be right in the world
and everything's gonna be totally fine
what does this button do
let me see how this works
come here
bam did that work
did that does that work
do i charge this in here
did that work
it didn't work it worked it didn't work
it worked it worked it didn't work
warning tampering with bath bear
automated steps the eyes are hard
work off the welcome
while you eat sign up for a membership
pass today
super cool
discounts on pizza nachos these buttons
change the maze
i don't know for those of you who are
saying like you can save after six i
can't
i can't
i can't no i cannot okay
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
this real quick like we're gonna be done
in a flash i already know what i need i
need this one over there that's in row
four
from top to bottom
so i just need four to go
down
no not five four
twice
and i moved that up there and now i need
to switch it over to lefty ready mode
and then i need to move one over left
boink please tell me that was one nope i
pressed some other button
i think three
yep okay now that is there and that
should be
yes now that is accessible so
now
this took me forever just to figure out
how this thing works so i need to move
uh
i could probably move yeah what if i
move that blue over so i move two to the
right
two goes to the right then there's a
path goes down there
that's there let's move three
uh
so i wonder if i move this over
with that open that up no that would not
open yeah
what if i move
three to the left
please be this one thank you
three over left okay that that's still
blocked off there
move one over one more
not four
okay
oh
wait a minute what no stop don't do this
to me not like this what happened why
did that that was open previously why
would that
be that way don't
do that don't don't do that to me
don't do that to me why would that have
done that why would ford
undo what you did why did that
maybe i maybe i'm thinking about this
wrong
did i hit two one accident i must have
hit two
on accident yes i must i did i hit two
on accident somehow
i'm not crazy
i'm not crazy what did i hit three
okay
good
we're good that's moving this chunk so i
need i need three on the verts see this
is all the stuff that i cut out that you
get to see
not that button
okay
what is moving this is three i need to
move
oh
no that's fine that's good okay now you
go
okay that goes there
is that a path is that a path that's not
a path because that's not there i need
to three on the horizontally
to go
this way
oh
come on now
over one more
aha
yep
okay
we got it
definitely got it
i got it
why did i get it i don't know
i like gunning it
their eyes have just become infinitely
harder to hit i don't know why but they
did so
there
leads to the is golf catwalks i believe
there is a control panel for the maze
around here somewhere
oh
okay i need to get this one out of there
so i'm gonna move it over one more
i'm gonna switch i'm gonna move it up no
i'm going to move this down because i'm
going to replace it with no i can't
replace it with that one i'm going to
replace it with
this one
oh my god i hate i hate this i don't
know why but my brain just can't do it
it's
hold on
because i'm moving this down now i don't
think that broke anything there because
that's still a clear path down there i'm
moving this here i don't need that one i
need
that one would also block me off all of
these would block me off why do they all
block me off
these are all the worst ones to possibly
have
why are they there
i don't know
but
whatever
maybe i could just go in the other door
maybe i could just do that
what if i just do that
there's two doors
why wouldn't i just is it open i can't
tell why like
is it open
no
but that's fine because i'll move it
over one more
oh we'll be right in the world because i
can go you open you're open okay you're
open where are you
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership oh good
it's all good i think i go this way in
this way and this way in this way and up
here and through here and then up
through and then suddenly i'm in the vet
and i gotta go slanty into him
okay
we're good
now we just beat this boss level first
try like i did before
we get the claw upgrade put them in like
i did before
wouldn't you know it we got everything
we need
just like that
can't save that's fine
okay
this is fine
welcome to the party buddy
welcome to the party
it's gonna be a good time now that
you're here
thank you
just uh be nice
rock and roll you'll never be bonding
you'll literally never be as good as
bonnie
[Music]
easy okay i think i missed like all of
those shots
for some reason
don't know why
nope
oh it broke
[Music]
no thank you
i don't want any
where did he
go
oh god oh god
no
no i could have shot all this
okay just a few more i could have just
shot him i don't know why i didn't
whoa where are you going
hi bud
hey big guy okay
all right
so you want to be it's fine
oh one i'm probably
whoa hey pal
let me just get that last one
yes there it is okay
okay and monty um hey how do you feel
about falls from great heights
okay we're fine
and
easy
all right here we go
easy peasy
okay
all right we're good there we're all
good
thank you i forget how did i get out of
here again
it's our back way
goes the back way oh i gotta collect the
claws that's right
and then i do
what exactly
oh right go up here for the vent
that's what it was
is there gonna be a music man in this
vent i can't remember if there was i
have a feeling there was
i'm good
oh okay good good good all right okay i
hear you guys you annoying spamming
i hear you you are talking
about
bugging the game out you're talking
about cr you're talking about cheating
and there's one thing that i've never
been more disappointed in you for than
suggesting that i an honorable gamer
should cheat how
dare you how you know what how dare you
suggest that i would stoop to the level
of cheating do you understand how that
would disgrace me and who i am as a
person as a human being
you should look in the mirror and you
should take a long hard look at yourself
forever suggesting even the idea
of cheating
this is the moment where there are no
saves that is what this moment is about
so why don't you just go away
take a breather and never come at me
suggesting to cheat in an experience
ever again
i will not have it
i will not have it in this house
i will not have it you should be ashamed
of yourself because i am ashamed of you
now what was it you were saying that i
had to do again something about roxy
raceway that i had to go back are you
saying something about roxy raceway i
think i remember i had to i left
something at roxy raceway i think i
remember
i think i remember that i had to go back
there for some reason i think uh
princess quest three was in roxy right
if i remember correctly i remember
i think i remember correctly that there
was uh definitely
definitely 100 something back there that
i needed and quick i needed it like now
oh man good thing i remembered that
thing that i needed which i definitely
needed
i needed that so i'm just gonna go back
there real quick and get it oh man
[Music]
anyway
just got a real quick i think i left my
car keys over there or something
just gotta
[Music]
all right so i have the claws i just
need to put in the upgrade
and then
i'll be good
oh roxy raceway is where you cheat oh i
don't want to go back there then i i
don't want to go there yeah no i'm not
going to do that i really i legitimately
am not because i do like the experience
how it feels when there's like no
turning back there's something about
that you know that that's what it that's
what made the hard modes feel hard and i
i don't know if this one has a real hard
mode if this is technically the hard
mode playing with no saves like that's
what it is you know that that's what it
is
and that's that's kind of like the whole
point so
that's what i'm gonna do um let me go
upgrade freddy now
but i have that oh i'm gonna go down
through here i'm gonna go down the
central thing and i'm not gonna screw up
the upgrade i didn't before i don't know
why i would
but i'm not gonna screw up the upgrade
and i'm gonna get going
you know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do
that i'm not ashamed of anyone that does
cheat it's fine like use whatever
advantage but uh i'm challenging myself
you know i gotta say i got some kind of
some kind of skill left in these old
really
oh this is bugged
man
do i gotta take the elevator down is
like roxy's elevator down is that what i
gotta do probably
oh maybe it's the thing where if i
haven't gone in like a recharge station
for some reason somehow
that like unbugs things sometimes sir
it says there's one like over there
oh yeah right i know where that one is
yeah
let me do the thing where i slap myself
in there
yeah
hold on hold on hold on hold on now hold
on hold on
hold on there
hold on
there's one like right here i thought
there was isn't it was that one right
here am i crazy wasn't there one right
here here was another one recharge
station
yes
yes okay yes
and also this is how i get back to
roxy's elevator so i'll just take that
it'll be quicker anyway
all right
bada bing
i know i should just be riding in freddy
but at this point i've done without for
so long and he's so slow i just can't
stand it i just can't stand it also he
smells bad smells like old blood and
rusty nails in there it's it's
unpleasant you know it's unpleasant
it's like the fresh air of not being
stuffed inside an animator we spent all
this time playing all these games trying
to avoid being stuffed in an animatronic
and now all of you guys are just like
yeah
let me in dad
i'mma hop in
no
no way
no way no how
no how
like comment and subscribe if you're
enjoying yourself in this experience
good
that's great
i'm guessing of a number between one and
a thousand
if you guess it correctly
i will give you
two dollars
guess now
[Music]
preparing for upgrade procedure
you may now enter the protective
cylinder oh you're close
you're close
you're close by opening the arm you
almost got it
all right everyone shut up i gotta
concentrate you keep guessing you keep
guessing
you better keep guessing
the contest will end after
i'm done did you match the pattern
correctly
okay
that's done click on the claws to pull
them out of the casing bam great now
place the new armature into the forearm
casing
with the new armature inserted reconnect
the colored wires
great job now close the casing
good job
now use the testing console to run
diagnostics and complete the procedure
do
oh you didn't guess it oh man time's up
guys i finished sorry you were so close
you were so close ah man the number was
like one number away
oh god man i'm sorry i'm sorry you won't
get the two dollars but that was a close
one you really did you the effort was
great i'm proud of you where did you get
these parts i'd rather not say
how fortunate i should now be able to
smash through the cyclone fences around
the building the way monty does exactly
like he did
exactly like he did okay
so now
freddy has all of the upgrades
all the upgrades
and that's wonderful because now we can
smash through gates which is also
wonderful
now the question is where do we need to
go
because i have
eight security batches
i'm willing to bet that i need like 10
somehow but i just got to figure out
where to go first
there the first place that i'm gonna
look into
the first place i'm gonna look into is
i know in the like basement area over
yonder way there was a chain-link fence
down there it's like in the earliest
part of the game
i'm gonna go down there
i think that there's like
there was a chain link fence down there
i just don't know
if it's actually like important
all right he's full charge so he should
be fine for the journey but i'm gonna do
it mostly on the foot just because
i'm not a and i'm i'm brave and i
don't need to worry about dying because
i'm so goddamn skilled at this game
and i don't think that there's any
security bots down there anyway
never mind friday
this freaking idiot oh hi
sorry i wasn't talking about you who you
talking about
not talking about you
okay
let's go downstairs
all right good job buddy
what
where
am i
oh
interesting
fascinating
they've ready nice claws
this is gold
why do i feel like i've
i got that one before already why do i
feel like i had though hey let me look
uh not here i have an actual inventory
golden freddy chica roxy monty i have
all of them
i mean it looks like i got the whole
collection what does that mean though
why was this one hidden
i don't know if there's anything that's
supposed to be done about that
i got flashlight upgrades i got lots of
fizzy fast i'm missing the chica fizzy
fast i don't know where that is
but i'm missing that one
also don't know what those do
interesting clothes just don't show up
apparently
hmm
interesting
okay
fascinating
well good job freddy there might be
another
oh don't
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
don't
okay it's not it's fine
that one's just stuck
it's fine
i'm not worried
why because i'm brave
okay now was there another gate down
here i'm not 100
that
yes
thank you for that
right the chica screen
right of course
thank you let's go
oh what is this
weird
comedy mask oh yeah that's hilarious
this looks familiar wait wasn't this
this was a
wasn't this something in uh help wanted
wasn't this a level in help wanted
literally
like
the
dolls of the vr game
i believe it was i believe it was
i believe it was let me just check my
map real quick
where does this go
aha
very good
oh freddy
your services are required
won't you come here and give this a good
scratch
all right we'll do it together
as a team
wham all right thank you for that can
you
there seem to be well oh perfect
perfect
it's okay freddy this is my stop please
let me out
thank you pal thank you friend
ah
good
whatever this is
missing what's missing
bonnie is seen leaving his green room in
rock star row heading east towards the
atrium 2 40 a.m bonnie enters the east
arcade 4 12 a.m bonnie enters monty golf
that's interesting
hi freddy
that's very interesting
i doubt that means that he's still there
that probably has to do with why he was
decommissioned in the first place but
that's still very interesting that that
was hidden behind that
literally a gate that i couldn't get
unless i'd been to monty golf
very interesting
oh freddy
freddie please
another one
monty killed
yeah maybe you know you might be right
this looks scary
monty may have killed bonnie
whoa what am i looking at what am i
looking at
what
what what
the hell is this
oh good
that's great
what is this supposed to be
okay
that's creepy don't know why this is
here and i don't want to know why
okay thanks
that's nightmare fuel
all right excuse me freddy you're in the
way here
something over here
yes
okay yay foxy haven't seen foxy
i'm not sure who i like better foxy or
roxy
but
miss having
foxy around
are you mourning warning tampering with
fazbear automated staff will result in
suspension of your membership it says
you can go down that way but i don't
think there's any way to go down there
huh
unless there's a way that you get in
from the back but i don't know
we'll see we'll see i think this is the
end of the stairwell
so i don't think there's anything else
to do there
this stairwell went up and it went to
the front atrium area
oh freddy
[Music]
thanks pal
you know just how to help you know just
how to help thank you very much for that
thank you very much oh there's another
one
ah too yes good good freddy
be a dear and tear this fence down for
me please thank you thank you
[Music]
wham
uh-huh oh
fascinating
where is this
what is this
wait a minute
this also looks familiar
from another game
a moon figure oh good this also looks
familiar why does it look familiar
there's a lot of stuff from the vr game
that might have also made its way into
this game you know what i mean it feels
like that anyway
huh oh did it was that here oh that
looks close
hold on one second everybody let me just
charge up make sure i don't
lose too much power where is that
is that the end of that hallway
but i can't get to that hallway
i don't think i can climb up that can i
there's no way
why are you being so creepy
do not warning tampering with fast fair
automated staff will result in
suspension of your membership
nah
maybe
probably not though
how did i do it before
okay
no no way
i'm gonna get myself stuck and it'll be
game over and i don't want to do that
why did you come running from all the
way down there
that is weird
huh
what is down there friend
why did you come a running
oh what the hell
hi
okay bye
all right anyway okay i don't know i
don't think that's accessible right now
i'm just gonna carry on
let's all go to the lobby
oh it was a longer journey to the lobby
than i remember okay but there might be
other doors that can be bashed open over
here too
probably
ready i get
i'm just looking to see if there's any
collectibles around here that i missed
there's that poster but i don't think
it's actually on this level i think it's
somewhere else
this however is here oh what's this
ah
there are more
there are many more that's right because
monty came crashing through that doorway
a while ago that would have already been
open
interesting glam freddy blush
beautiful he came bashing through this
ah
how did he not get through this
freddy
bam thank you buddy thank you pal
oh god oh god
oh god
okay
ready
almost buddy
you not quite
keep trying
ready
freddy
excuse me
okay thank you
all right and then
wham
this is where this is
i see what
what
is
that
what am i hearing on the other side of
what
in the hell
the hell it's there but you can't see it
alone in the dark i found the key
what are you doing
sorry pal
[Music]
exotic butters
oh wow exotic butters
this is the ending of sister location
wow
requires item
okay
interesting there's an item that i need
to use this
some kind of like tape
i'm guessing
or like a radio of some kind
okay
man there were a lot of secrets just in
this area hi pal where's your head
crazy
okay
all right
weird yeah all of it was like hidden
just in this first hallway that you went
through
and just coming back here again there's
like endless things to open up
it's kind of weird actually
this is the other side of that i don't
even know
weird
see this is what makes the game
really interesting like really
interesting i don't think you can get
through this can you
like it's it's a lot of
it's a lot of cool stuff
that's all just right here i just had a
thought but i don't know yet hang on one
second
i had a think thought a new wrinkle
formed in my brain
hold on
hmm
what if
where am i
where did this send me up
i don't remember coming through all of
this before i thought it was a more
direct route to the top
okay oh
no
oh come on i go all this way
i guess that's why you couldn't come
back
oh weird this doesn't open anymore
well i guess i gotta go the long way
back which is
unfortunate but okay
that's strange
weird
really
whoa
open the door freddy open the door open
the door open the door yes oh i s
i'm gonna cheat through because i'm
gonna get in here with him he's
oh
wow that's weird that's like a heart
what if i hop out
am i through
oh that's an interesting trick
oh that is an interesting trick
oh that is a very interesting trick
oh that is an extremely interesting
trick
now that's rick
that is indeed a trick
and here i am
oh
interesting
fascinating
good i'm ready
well well well
no no no no no
i didn't cheat i didn't cheat i didn't
cheat uh the game should have been built
better to prevent my incredible gameplay
it's not my fault that i'm playing at
such a high level that the game can't
keep up
it's a burden to be this good at games
as i am as thus let me
is we that i do
you know how hard it is to find a game
that can be an appropriate challenge for
me
is downright impossible sometimes
but last time i suppose of you no matter
what
can't let it get the best of me not that
anything can
[Music]
anyway
time to continue on this adventure
although i already know how it's going
to end i can't get through that
all right anyway
whatever cheating's cool come on guys
come on please please don't get caught
right now
i think i saw another gift in here yes i
did
all right so
now what i need oh the fizzy fazz i do i
run faster do i run longer is this like
a stamina up i have no idea whatever
it's probably good for me but i got all
the fizzy fast now
cool also messages what is false alarm a
local police officer came by tonight he
said he was responding to an emergency
call from someone inside the pizza plex
there is no way that is possible i was
the only one here and i certainly didn't
make any outside calls he wanted to look
around but i sent him away just another
prank call
all right
so you say
friend vanessa
all right credit
ready
we need to get you charged up soon
i think there's one in the daycare
that'd be easy enough i'm just scanning
around real quick up yep i missed a
couple oh no i would have gotten these
already but
wait
what the hell no i definitely got that
one because that one is
that one is uh
that's the magnet
that i used on the machine on the other
side i found the free gift uh it's a
crappy mr hippo fridge magnet
lame
i am sorry gregory
i am
truly sorry so sorry okay well that is
so let me just triple check
and speed pop there we go where are we
going buddy where are we going buddy
all right man i mean i missed so many of
these i miss so many
god
how did i oh where is that
oh i know where that is that's that's
awful okay
sorry lag my internet's crap i know guys
i know i know it's coming back it's back
just refresh if it's if you can't hear
me properly just refresh it'll come back
hold on please panic panic more scream
louder
panic everybody panic scream
it's chaos it's calamity scream
panic run for the hills
it's lag
it's lag all right whatever
was there anything in the daycare that
could be open opened by the claws
i don't remember any
there might have been something was
there anything here
i mean i still wonder how to get back
there because that's a mystery
yeah i don't know what that's about i
don't even remember the shape of that
room being anything but
there it is
yeah i don't think so maybe back that
way
oh maybe it is back that way
oh yeah the one back there okay
all right all right hold on hold on hold
on
hold on
gotta figure out what's back behind that
gate
what
nothing's behind that gate because it's
out of order
all right so that is not helpful
i know that there's a ton of
collectibles in
here
let me just use my
division or roxy
okay there's three four
no that's open one two
three four things that i needed to get
that i did not get where is that
where is that
what
is it worth getting
good i might as well you know i might as
well just double check everything to
make sure that there wasn't a door here
that i was supposed to go through
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will reward him suspending of your
master their
[Music]
well i could have saved myself some time
by not doing that but i didn't
um i think it was
this one or the next one
i know if i was just in freddy this
wouldn't be a problem but i'm not
okay that's a problem now i now have a
problem freddy get over here get your
ass
ass here ass here now on the double on
the double
listen guys i just
i just don't like being inside for ready
i'm just gonna say it
just don't like being inside freddy this
is just the way it is i don't know what
to tell you other than that that's just
what it is
okay
no i'm look i'm also looking to see if
there's like any uh side doors here that
are
like
well
oh my god
goodness gracious
i could just get in freddy i could i
know i could i have the capability to do
that i know that's within my power and
yet i don't i don't know why
i'm not sure
but i don't freddie come here
come here boy
all right
okay
so i got that one wait
no i got that one okay there was one in
here how did i miss that
i'm so incredibly dumb that i can't see
this thing right in front of my face
okay
we're good we're good we're good we're
good
i keep jump scaring myself because i
think i'm going to do something stupid
die
but there's no way that i could do that
because everything is totally fine what
is over there
i don't even think i can get there can i
i don't think i can how would i get over
there what is over there
how do you get over there
what
as long as freddy's fat ass could jump
because i don't think i can give him the
play area anymore because moon man's
such an that he won't let me
i don't even know where that was
pointing
where was that pointing
weird
no
okay
all right
i know there was nothing down in the
basement because i checked that already
and i saw that there was nothing so
there's nothing over there
there's nothing here there was nothing
in this arcade
i don't think anyway
yeah definitely nothing in the arcade
okay
i think we're all set here
uh
the poster in the theater
all right
all right you've peaked my interest
you've peaked my interest i'm interested
i'm curious
let's see what is the deal
that poster there on the other side over
there
that poster there is that the poster
you're talking about
if i do the same thing i did on the one
down below is that gonna do the thing
damn you
this
not that
hello
ready
no
i think it would i think it would do the
thing where it had an outline like it
did before
otherwise you know
what's back here no that just leads back
to there oh god don't run out of power
and kill me do not run out of power and
kill me
don't do it
ugh
what's it
downstairs cardboard characters
what are you talking about
speak clearly
use your words
what are you talking about there's
nothing here
there's nothing
i need to find the characters from the
pokemon
kind of
what kind of obscure ass minigame would
that be
these guys
oh
whoa
i see
only i had more
charge
huh
no
i don't remember what was on the poster
whoa
the hell oh no oh no you don't oh no you
don't oh no you oh no freddy is oh no
what was that what happened
are you activated
no you're not don't
dick with me
i don't think i've been up here wait
where's here what's here
why is this up here
what's the point of this
disappointing any of this
okay all right well that gave me a
fright okay i'm gonna go back and look
at the picture the poster and then
come back
unless they're all down here in
different places but i don't even
remember what the poster looked like so
i'm gonna go back and take a gland or
and then come back downstairs
warning tampering with fazbear automated
staff will result in suspension of your
membership
aha okay
pirate okay
chica
that i've seen
i've seen these before
the chica mermaid
weird
interesting
i don't think that there was another one
of these guys down there
but the chica mermaid is out in the
atrium and that guy i think i've seen in
like the
the
phaser blast little back room there
something
just so happens to be my time
that's interesting
and if i have to go back to the basement
because i missed one there that's fine
i'm not too worried about that that's at
least relatively nearby
okay
okay that was a fruitful adventure
lad guys panic scream scream at the top
of your lungs panic
it's the lag
the leg
all right
we're doing good guys we're doing good
we're doing good we're doing very good
refresh if you've got audio problems
that's totally fine
we're doing good we're doing real good
temperature
automated and dispensing of your
membership
oh wait was that it
no that was not it there's got to be
more there's got to be more right
there's got to be more
there's more
i know there's more
okay
all right okay
i'm gonna continue on
come back to that later because i i
i i have seen those other characters
before and i think it's like i gotta get
old
so i don't have all of them so i'm not
gonna go back it's not open yet i gotta
do other things
no i it wasn't done it wasn't done guys
it wasn't done i know it wasn't done 100
was not done
[Music]
that the lack of 80s
very funny
very funny hilarious actually
oh my god the elephant takes so long
okay
so now we're back here
what we need to do is we need to
do something
we've got a lot of
ground to cover
yeah the problem is there's so much
place
and i don't know exactly what needs to
be clawed open what needs to be done
i'm not 100 sure about all those things
because there's a lot of things that i
could potentially do i just don't know
what needs to be done
like and there's some places that are
like clawed open that i could already
access so that i can kind of eliminate
was there anything in the prize counter
there was something it said about going
to the prize counter for some reason it
wanted me to go to the prize counter
like real bad
but i just don't remember what it was
there was nothing in the bonnie bowl i
know that
i don't think that there was actually
anything in in the dance
area
i don't think so anyway
let me check the superstar kid because
that's at least one place that i haven't
thoroughly explored
mazer size definitely didn't i know that
didn't
unless it definitely did
and i'm just dumb
it's entirely possible
and eventually yes i will go to fox's
raceway but not for the reasons that you
want me to go you cheaters
i want to go somewhere else
i'm going to go here i want to explore
this area
nothing there nothing there
nothing there
okay
this is a bathroom
what's behind there
why are you so slow
hurry up
there you are
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership why are you patrolling this
bathroom who did that
no
i say no warning tampering with the
fazbear automated staff will result in
suspension of your membership no no it
won't
no i don't think that there's anything
here
because i doubt unless that like
somewhere in here is like
the
balloon boy world or whatever it is
it might be in here but i don't have the
patience to look for that
there's no way that i'm gonna look for
that
i would have to comb through every
single inch of this place warning
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership
oh my god are you kidding me
are you serious
oh god
ah this is the tunnel back to the prize
counter well then i didn't even need to
go this way
i just needed to get to the prize area
i don't think that there's anything in
the prize area either
yeah there was nothing here
unless let me get freddy
really
i can't have freddy back here
why
give me one good reason
this is a bunch of baloney
a bunch of baloney
it's a bunch of baloney
i'm finally behind the counter that's
going to do me any good not that i know
why i would need to in the first place
nothing back here
and then nothing over here
and this just leads back out okay so
this was a big waste of time i didn't
need to come here at all
but that's fine
that's the nature of the game
i explore where i need to go when i
fail when i need to fail
oh
that went the wrong way
oops
oh my god they got the slowest security
guard in the world
[Music]
there we go
all right so i know there's another
cutout for that poster thing i don't
know what the poster thing is about but
i know that there's another cutout down
here
in
i think in there right yeah i see it i
see it i see it i see it i see it i see
it if you don't see it look harder
it's right back there in this like
children's cove area whatever it's
called
there that one
if i take a picture of that
and the eye glows and that means it's
another part of the poster that's the
only time that i've seen that one
is it though maybe there's another one
maybe i'm wrong about that
i might be wrong i might be stupid
i might be i might just be guys guys i
might just be stupid
wow
i'm stupid i'm dumb i didn't do it right
freddy help
no freddie please
i don't know of any way to get like the
level 10 pass i don't even know how you
could
maybe i should go into the golf area
because i've never really been able to
explore a lot of the gulf area
i kind of was always in and out
but i'm wondering
i'm wondering if there's some things
back here that's
lurking
i know i've seen those other cutouts
somewhere else but i think it was
it's always in like some back room or
someplace some side room
that i've never seen before
yeah i'm gonna get to roxy's raceway i'm
gonna get there eventually but i'm i'm
combing through the building uh looking
for secrets
in case it wasn't obvious
i'm trying to be methodical and thorough
in my investigation
friday
whoa freddie hi
hey pal how you doing good to see you
let's go for a venture
let's see there's a lot of stuff here
that i've missed
hello officer how are you doing good to
see you keep up the good work
okay something down there
this would be a pretty fun golf course i
got it this would be pretty nice
gator grub no i've already been there
something up here
i believe at some point in the past i've
gotten this thing but
oh why
holy crap
don't
you do nothing
no one's really been coming after me
when they do those things i got an
entire go-kart
i got an entire go-kart guys i didn't
even need anything
else i didn't even need anything
all right let's see you got that
one one other thing over there
i don't get over there
how do i get there
oh
gregory
this is such fun
i love a ball pit
you're a real superstar
okay am i back okay it really uh
my internet is getting like less stable
by the second i have no idea what's
going on this is very bizarre
uh but you know
i uh
i'm committed to this what is this
where's there a slide leads down there
what
okay
all right
hey how you doing i'm back
uh let me go charge up i know there's a
charger right here
if it works i hope it does
let me charge up and then um i think i
got everything i needed here and i don't
think that there was anything in the
back that had like things that i could
open up yeah refresh if you're
if you're all kinds of
turbulated
just give it a good old refresh and that
should sort it out
kind of think
right
there's something else going on
something else to do here
is something else
oh
did i oh i i don't remember if i got the
things here before or after i died
because i remember i died getting all
these things
on the time i went and got all these
things i don't know if i kept them
though
did i get them
oh i did not get them goddamn that was
before i died
okay
oh the golden sun
what does that mean there's a golden
moon is that what that is
i know i've already gotten that one but
i guess there are more golden figurines
to be had
hello can i have this please thank you
the moon plush not the golden moon plush
that's the only two
i'm here i'm stuck
oh god
there we go
okay
i missed one over there god damn it i'm
an idiot
how did i miss that one i was like right
there
i know i tried it
i tried it i tried oh
oh
i see
ah
interesting
interesting i see
fascinating
the lore
the lore everyone
the lord
i don't think that there's another one
over here
i think that this might be
i'm talking about the cutout not this
necessarily what i'm looking at right
now
there was also one that was in the brush
back here
if i remember
yes
i should have been looking for these a
bit more carefully before
because then i wouldn't have to
backtrack so much but
it is fine
i'll be all right
i will survive
i don't know if there were another
or any other paths back here that needed
to be scratched open i think most of the
places that would be scratched
would probably be in the back tunnels or
underground areas and i think this just
leads
back to the atrium
yeah this leads back here
which is not where i need to be but let
me double check it and just take a
gander with freddy
real quick
somewhere back there
freddy
thank you
you didn't literally have to run all the
way from where you were before you could
have teleported but that's okay i
forgive you
okay there's something unopened there
ah let's find out what it is
most of those are opened opened open
that's unopened
this is unopened
oh
how did i this is the oh
how did i miss this
how the hell did i miss this i don't
know
this was oh whoa collect where what am i
looking at what am i collecting i don't
see anything what are you talking about
here ah
all right then
right the other idea that i had
there was something else here
hold on everybody hold on to your butts
hold on to your butts
doesn't say level 10 anymore
hold on your butts
it was there
the cd
okay these aren't part of it
no these aren't the ones i don't need
those was there a cutout that was back
in the cutout area
back there
there might have been
it's pretty wide coverage if it wasn't
bam
ah sorry about
sorry bill
didn't mean to i apologize where does
this go
oh where the hell does this go
oh this is just the rehearsal area
oh you don't think there was anything
back there but there probably is i
should probably go there and i should
probably check it out but
i don't really want to
yeah i'm not gonna do it
i'm not gonna do that
yeah i'm not gonna do that
this is where the freddy cutout is is it
are you sure
where i just was oh
oh
i knew i should go back there i knew
that was a test that was a test to see
if you were up to my normal level of
commitment and attention to detail that
i obviously am
right of course it's back there
of course it is
i knew it
i always suspected it
in fact i knew for a fact it was back
there 100
the entire time
because i'm
so goddamn smart and so goddamn good at
this
all right whatever i'm gonna stop being
all egotistical officially now i'm never
gonna be egotistical again
and i swear
i always keep my promises
always forever i've never not kept a
promise in my entire life
that's amazingly ah it was here
so the only one left is the bonnie one
right
what are you doing back here
there's a bonnie
the bun no not back here not back there
no way not back there there was a bonnie
one wasn't it like
in
phasor blast it was like that back room
in the back ass of phaser blast
right
wasn't it
i think i remember seeing maybe it
wasn't that one
bonnie at the end of arcade hallway
i'll trust you on it i'll trust you i'm
trusting you on it okay i'm trusting you
on that i'm gonna go there and then i go
all the way back to the daycare and then
i'll go all the way back
all right i'll do it i'll do it for you
i'll do it uh let me charge
radio
it was in our kit right there was an
arcade machine in monty golf i knew that
there was something going on there but
i'll get to that in a moment i'll get to
that in a moment i'll get to that in a
moment
i'll get to that in just a hot second i
got other business to attend to
oh he's so slow that i really don't want
to have to wait how about i miss present
there he's just so slow
yeah yeah
i got you i'm hearing you i'm hearing
you loud and clear i got you i'm hearing
you i'm hearing you loud and i got you i
got you you're gonna see the lore this
probably isn't gonna lead to any kind of
an ending but it's gonna be another
secret room that took way too long to
get to and we'll be barely rewarding for
what the effort was
but i'll do it i hear ya i hear you i
don't remember seeing a bonnie cut out
back there but you're probably right
you're probably absolutely right you're
probably 100 absolutely right
yeah
i just got to figure out where it is
by the way
there's a link in the description that
will take you to distractible it's a
podcast that bob wade and i have made
i think you're going to enjoy it if you
want to have a laugh just go listen to
it what's it gonna do kill you
well it's free it doesn't even cost
anything it's free it's content you like
bob and way don't you
i thought you liked them
i guess not oh you are here
ready
for oh
you are here
i didn't know you were here all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna ride him up because
i'm not risking this area because i know
that chica is still up there and there's
a present back there apparently i'll get
that on the way out
i'm not risking anything now i've come
so far and if i die at this point i'm
gonna be so mad chica's just like
permanently here
that's just where she is now
which is
comforting to know that people just are
consistent like that
don't know why though but it makes it
good because i don't have to worry about
her being anywhere else at least
oh it sucks up so much power to get
through here
all right thank you
thank you thank you freddie you're such
a delight appreciate you all right
so somewhere back here there's a cut out
it might be all the way at the end of
the hallway yeah
i haven't seen much bonnie so it would
stand out
i think anyway
maybe maybe not
i do not know
um
man it's like i should have gone golfing
when i first did it oh he is there
well that would be all of them right
i've already played princess quest 2
so i don't need to do that
so should be good now
right that should have been all the
characters i don't think that there was
anything else
that's all for i think
so i go back to the daycare
i go through all that stuff and i'm good
to go
right i'm not going to ride freddie back
because i just don't have enough power
and he's going to kill me if i
pop into my know he will
i'm just going to zap chica i'm just a
zapper
not risking
not risking it i always say that right
before i die
but i'm not risking it not this time
where you going that's right
where's she where is she
whoa my god god damn you
no where
where oh no
um
gregory you have a choice to make
the door is open well
we saw her hideout right
and phaserblast
maybe we could catch her there
if she thinks i escaped maybe we can
surprise her yes come
let us end this
i'm trying to skip it's not letting me
skip
i
can't
i can't
let
oh my god i want to skip you gave me the
option and yeah it's not here you said
skip and it's not skipping i guess just
another thing that doesn't quite work
the way it's supposed to
oh my god oh my god i just
i'm so
what is even happening where am i
i don't have the camera i don't have
anything i lost so much the reason i'm
going here is because i know that
princess quest iii is in vanna's room
and i think i go to vanity's room here
what what
yeah no it's it's just one of those
things where it's like
god i'm trying to be so careful and
chica spawns on top of me and that kills
me saw her hide out right that's what
does it
like maybe that's so
unfair don't surprise her i'm fine if my
skill is bad and i
intentionally do something that's wrong
and it messes up and i still can't skip
this
like
i'm fine
period
very good very good very fine i'm fine
but i'm fine but it's like come
on
why
would you have a situation where you
could
have something like that happen
like i was right ah
i wasn't careless
that's the other thing i wasn't careless
i was looking around like oh where is
chica i know the chica's there and just
right
i just
cannot overstate this concept
are you coming
right for me
i don't know i just
i'm fine i'm good i am so good
i'm do you think you're better than me
yeah apparently i don't know
maybe
oh
still just you
it's fine though i got all those golden
things i got all the
drinks i got everything it's fine
tampering with fazbear automated staff
will result in suspension of your
membership
oh look it's chica surprise you didn't
spawn right on top of me
that would have been in character
okay
right
so i'm going here for a different reason
than just getting this ending it's
because this is here
right
princess quest three so at least this is
something that i can do
right yo
fascinating
oh
back here
interesting
oh my god
i do not have a lot of health here
please don't
nope
out please don't
oh god oh
i'm out of um
what oh
okay weird
whatever all right it's fine it's fine
it's fine maybe i'll just run out nope
that's not an option
i'm stuck
help
i'm dead apparently
no it's fine it's fine fine i'm
good at games
let me go down see what's in here
yeah it's just hard to gauge the range
on this thing
because it does have some range i just
don't know where it is
okay
okay i'm i'm tuning it in i've got it
right on the edge of the sword
okay better better better better better
okay so what's in here
oh
it is the pizzeria okay there's a lock
there it's not really a
door am i to argue
oh oh oh
oh
oh they're like oh no
hi welcome back it's fine
the lag is over it's it's all good now
we're all happy and fine and i'm trying
to figure out how to go here
this seems like the uh there was a
five nights at freddy's vr
maze that i went through a while back
that had foxy stalking you
it's kind of reminiscent of that hello
oh something's not right um
no yeah something's not right
that's a little weird why did i get that
it's a lag of 21. hey you got that right
yeah they're right pal
all right i'm i think i'm done here
i don't know what else there could be
but i have a
mask
oh how nice good good thing i have a
tendency to explore dark areas that no
one else would actually go to but i do
because i'm insane
i don't typically hop on a conveyor
first thing
oh
i'll get on the conveyor then
okay
we're just gonna ignore that
i'm not gonna pay attention to that why
would we
zap
hi hello
okay
what is this feeling a strength
oh god what are you doing what are you
doing
okay
so there's some kind of convoluted
conveyor system but why
oh
well that reversed them great
good
oh
oh interesting
ah
do i have to somehow get there at the
same time
no
okay
all right
something is not right no
something is not right here what's with
all the bunnies why is bonnie missing
what is with any of this
why is it all like this
why does it all come down to princess
quest 2
and 3 which is what i'm currently
playing
why is chica looking at me like that
what are you looking at
it's all fine
probably
yeah these aren't keys though i don't
think
oh
oh yeah that's right
that's through here i don't think i can
touch that
i can touch it strange key i wonder what
it opens
i don't
oh
oh my god
go away
go away hey go away
stop it is going to be a bullet hell i'm
a crawl
that's right i can take you
listen i'm if i could fight chica like
fist fight not my dog my dog is sweet
and she would definitely beat me up
but chica the animatronic in this game
five nights at freddy's security breach
i would
oh
wasn't that the door from the end of
help wanted as well the lock and key
door whoa
[Music]
the end
of five nights at freddy's security
breach
hmm
i could
yeah i saw the three stars there too i
thought three stars so that's it
i could
probably make a lot of guesses about
what the story is but i don't know
enough about like the backstory of five
nights at freddy's i've never read any
of the books or things like that and
there's a lot of people out there on
youtube that have done in-depth lore
views and stuff like that you know the
matpats and other folks of the world
and i know that that's probably not the
true ending i know that i'm 100 certain
of that
that's fine
i get that
however
i just want to wrap this up here because
i don't want to go through two and a
half hours of crawling through tunnels
to get everything that i just got again
to go through just to get that true
ending um
it'd be great if it was like a challenge
like you know it was tough and something
that i could really skill-based beat
that's fine
i just don't want to i i got my
enjoyment out of it through the crawling
and the exploring and stuff like that
and this was satisfying enough and i
knew that this was here that i could do
this i
i'm happy that i was able to get those
saves in with the other stuff first
before i got to this point and got here
um let me get to the end of the credits
because i don't know if there's gonna be
something at the end of the credits now
there wasn't before because obviously it
wasn't a real ending um
but i would say that this is probably
the good ending but the good ending is
never the true ending of anything um and
i'm not gonna leave just yet because i
do want to like wrap up my thoughts
about this game and like what it is and
five nights at freddy's and where it
stands right now i know it's not the
ending i know i know it's not i'd say
i'd say that was like it's unending it's
not the ending whatever i get it there's
a lot more secrets and there's a lot
more puzzles and there's a lot of stuff
for people that are really really really
into finding that kind of stuff and if i
ever do it again which i might i might
still do another one i would definitely
do that whatever exploit i was talking
about but going to roxy's raceway and
getting like the save to actually come
back
because
i know i know i know i'm i'm getting
there i'm getting there
hold on
hold your horses
if if everyone is able to be quiet in
chat for one minute
i will reveal the truth of the bite of
but only if you're able to hold your
mouths closed and your fingers closed
for just one minute
oh look at that
[Music]
that's lovely that's lovely
that's lovely oh
guess you couldn't stop talk it's all
good guys it's all good i'll tell you
the truth of the bite of 87 at another
day anyway i'm actually all out of time
and i'm
tired and it's too warm in this room and
i think i'm gonna call it for now
because it would just take me way too
long to get back to where i was now that
doesn't mean that i'm done
i want to be very clear that doesn't
mean that i'm done with this i may or
may not do another stream tomorrow where
i actually try to do it or i'll make
another video about it i don't know but
i need to take a break i'm hungry i'm
gonna do that but i do want to wrap up
like my thoughts about the game and some
things that i i think i'm piecing
together about my experience and it's
what i was saying there before as
frustrated as i can get it doesn't mean
that i dislike the game because there is
like love put into a lot of the corners
of this game there's not a lot of polish
in some places and the experience
overall feels a little disconnected and
i was talking about it before how
it almost seems like there's another
game that was here originally and it
didn't come fully true and a lot of the
game's funness actually does come from
kind of like going around and exploring
the whole thing and i'd like to think
that the game used to be you just go
around the whole place exploring finding
things all these mini games and stuff
were here but the timing system actually
was spaced out like you only had six
hours to do it and every hour like at
the end of our hour was like a crisis
that happened so it was it was i believe
it was something like that but that
doesn't matter i do enjoy this and i
think the experience is very good um
i will however do
all of the endings
that's something that you can guarantee
for me i'm not a quitter
i'm not a quitter if there's one thing
that i'm not
it's quitter and i already want to go at
it again but i just don't have time to
do another two and a half hours of it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
i really appreciate you being here this
was a fun time uh hopefully my internet
is a little better next time if i do do
another stream i will let you know or
you will see a video pop up
thank you
take care of yourselves take care of
each other and
there's a link in the description for
distractible it's so funny
we have such a good time
people have listened to it they love it
go give it a try
link is in the description hey check out
cloakbrand.com
it's my clothing i'd be wearing it right
now but it's super hot in this room and
i'm like basically dying whatever
so thank you
links are down there
thank you everybody so much for watching
i'll be back tomorrow with more of this
don't you worry your pretty little hat
and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
bye guys bye goodbye farewell goodbye